aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'
emilie du châtelet dont j'ai entendu
parler par ci par là comme étant celle
qui avait traduit le prime qui perd
mathematica de newton en français et du
coup il commence à m'intéresser à elles
à cause de cette raison et je me suis
rendu compte petit petit qu'elle avait
un rôle peut-être bien plus important
dans l'histoire des sciences des
mathématiques mais aussi de la france
que ce qu'on pourrait croire de prime
abord fait j'irais même jusqu'à dire
qu'elle est la mère des sciences
française est bon je vais y aller avec
des pincettes
je sais que j'exagère un petit peu en
disant cela mais je vais essayer de vous
montrer que je n'exagère pas tant que
cela doit être la mère des sciences
française qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
voudrait dire que en gros avant emilie
du châtelet y avait pas grand chose
conscience française est qu après emi du
châtelet savard a complètement explosé
et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
commencé à me dire petit à petit en
lisant sur lui du châtelet et dans moi
j'ai émis cette hypothèse et j'ai eu une
approche là des scientifiques c'est à
dire que j'ai émis cette hypothèse avant
d'avoir tout lu et je me suis je me suis
demandé comment est ce que je pourrai
montrer que l'affirmation sur laquelle
emilie du châtelet est la mère des
sources françaises est vraie ou fausse
pour cela je me suis dit ce qui
montrerait ça bien c'est si le nombre de
scientifiques français de mathématiciens
français de temps de très grand renom a
explosé quelques années ou quelques
décennies après par exemple notamment la
publication du prix guy béart
mathematica par emilie du châtelet
alors il faut savoir qu amy duchâtelet
est né en 1706 c'est qu'elle est morte
en 1749 et que sa traduction des primes
qui permet thématique ya aura lieu juste
après sa mort donc qu en 1749
du coup ce qu'on a vraiment faire c'est
comparer les sciences et les
mathématiques en france avant bien avant
1749 en fait on va regarder avant de
1666 ensuite on va voir l'état des
mathématiques et des sciences
contemporaines à midi
on voit entre 1966 et 1749
et enfin on va parler des mathématiques
et des sciences
après midi du châtelet or avant d'aller
plus loin il faut quand même dire
qu'avant emilie du châtelet
il existait des maths et des sciences en
france et même avant 1666 des
mathématiques et des sciences de très
haut niveau puisqu'il y avait des gens
comme rené descartes ou pierre de fermat
qui était vraiment très très haut niveau
puis on avait d'autres comme blaise
pascal ou marin mersenne qui était aussi
de niveau mondial quasiment à l'époque
mais ça c'était avant que 666 les quatre
mathématicien que je viens de citer sont
tous morts avant 1666 pourquoi j'insiste
sur 1666-1672 c'est l'année de la peste
à l'ordre c'est l'année où du town du
coup de fuir londres pour habiter avec
sa mère et son père adoptif en campagne
et c'est donc à ce moment là qu'une
pomme serait tombé sur sa tête et qu'il
aura eu cette idée de génie d'unifier
les lois du cosmos et de la terre et
donc la révolution citoyenne commence en
1666 en particulier les quatre
mathématicien que j'ai cités sont près
du podium on met ses 66
émile châtelaine et encore des aînés en
1706 mais entre lui 666 et en gros 1749
on va parler des exceptions près mais en
gros dans toute cette période là je peux
glisser les mathématiciens et les
scientifiques de ces français de cette
période
alors il ya pierre lui moreau de
maupertuis alexis claude claireaux
guillaume hamon ton gilles de roberval
et pierre varillon en tant que
mathématicien
si vous en connaissez aucun c'est tout à
fait normalement je reconnaissais au
caire non plus elle je connais aucun
théorème alors n'ont jamais entendu
lormont où que ce soit autant dire que
ce ne sont absolument pas des
mathématiciens de premier rang il ya
aussi des scientifiques à cette période
edmée marriott jean picard est un
excellent réaumur pareil je les connais
pas du tout
c'est pas du tout ce qu'ils ont fait
peut-être qu'ils sont connus parce que
je connais pas très bien les autres
sciences pas aussi des résolutions ce
cas les mathématiques mais ils montrent
pas du tout l'air important et puis jean
picard faut pas le confondre avec émile
picard qui est un grand mathématicien
mais du dix neuvième siècle
sahin avoir exemple car le seul
scientifique de les contemporains de
d'emilie du chapelet que je connaissais
ces gens rejouer leclerc de buffon qui
était vraiment un contemporain de dénis
duchatel puisqu'il avait à peu près le
même âge les midgets l'air dans deux
mois en fait j'en ai déjà parlé de
buffon puisque j'ai parlé dans l'épisode
où je parle le pied puisque du fonds à
hauteur de 2 7 à 2 expérience ou façon
de calculer pic de six étages était d
aiguille sur un quai de gare
bon allez voir l'épisode si vous voulez
en savoir plus donc lui font vraiment
mathématicien avec quelques trucs
intéressants il a aussi calculé la terre
avec une méthode assez ingénieuse assez
assez cool mais ces fausses aussi et
enfin il a eu des élans naturaliste
révolutionnaire mais qui n'a pas
totalement assumé une très bonne vidéo
de efficace que sur la vie depuis
et c'est à peu près tout à l'époque d
ennemi du châtelet et on boit on peut
dire qu'il est du châtel été mais de
loin la plus grande des mathématiciens
de son temps puisque a été la seule à
comprendre ou suffisamment la théorie de
newton pour pouvoir la traduire en
théorie qui qui n'était pas du tout
écrit dans le langage moderne
d'aujourd'hui qui est beaucoup plus
facile à comprendre
il était écrit dans le langage des
fluxion et de la géométrie pour faire
des véhicules différentiel en tout cas
c'est affreux aujourd'hui qu'on
n'utilise pas du tout aujourd'hui
et du coup ça laissait de l'être
vraiment un tour de force en fait
vraiment malin pour réussir à comprendre
tout le bouquin isaac newton
l'autre remarque importante affaire bien
sûr c est qu à ce moment là la faune ca
car des décennies de retard sur les
mathématiques des pays voisins en
particulier à cette époque là on peut
penser à newton
angleterre ou à paillettes strass bayas
très grands mathématiciens si en suisse
il y à la dynastie des bernouilli bien
sûr qui coule et jacob
yoann et compagnie et puis surtout il ya
un certain leonardo et leur qu'à cette
époque-là doit passer de berlin elle a
réussi quelque chose comme ça donc tous
les autres pays l'ont leurs grands
génies qui sont vraiment à la punta la
botte largement au dessus des années
lumière de ce qui se fait en france
la france est attardé à ce moment là sur
une thématique plafond s'est attardé
avant 1740
mais après 1749 la publication de la
traduction du compte il ya mathematica
par emilie du châtelet dans des
conditions sur lesquelles je veux
revenir un peu atroce on va assister à
une floraison merveilleuse à une
explosion des mathématiques et des
sciences française avec des grands des
futurs grands mathématiciens et
scientifiques comme jean baptiste
d'alembert qui est ce qui moi en 1740 à
fab 32 ans
même si johan d'ambert qui à ce
moment-là 22 ans qui devait par exemple
l'épisode sur la cartographie puisque
j'allais aubert a travaillé notamment
sur des mathématisation et de la
cartographie qui a requiert notamment du
calcul différentiel qui leur a sans
doute appris des écrits de madame du
châtelet
on va aussi voir arriver dans charles de
borda et nicolas de condorcet qui vont
devenir de deux ennemis intimes sûr
qu'ils vont travailler notamment sur les
systèmes de vote qu'ils n'approchent
très mathématique tout il faudra
absolument que je vous parle un jour en
1749 qu'ils ont respectivement 16 ans et
6 ans puis on a aussi gaspard monge qui
va être l'auteur du problème dit de
montgeron problèmes de transport optimal
donc on a des tas de sable à gauche à
droite on veut réunir ses tables en deux
ou trois tas de sable
la question c'est vers quel tas de sable
chaque morceau de sable
allez bo peut paraître un peu bizarre
comme ça mais c'est un problème
mathématique mais très important sur
lequel notamment un certain cédric
villani a travaillé donc la v5
mathématicien que je vous ai six décès
des mathématiciens qui était né en 1749
et bien sûr a pu imaginer qu'avec les
méthodes de l'époque et en publications
les pans de lecture et puis la fête les
profits bon il faut que les professeurs
et élus soutien aux produits bien
l'enseigné peut-être sont-elles une ou
deux générations pour que ça explose
complètement est en effet ce n'est plus
une ou deux générations plus tard que ça
va encore plus exposés complètement avec
une génération de mathématiciens et de
scientifiques qui vont vraiment devenir
à la pointe des mathématiques et des
sciences mondiale cette fois donc on
peut citer notamment pierre simon de
laplace qui va devenir un leader mondial
notamment en astronomie
tout ça va en utilisant à foison et
mathématiques de newton et s'il y avait
encore une fois c'est sans doute grâce à
emilie du châtelet
pierre simon laplace une exactement en
1749 l'année où les points qu'il
affectionne et qui permette matica est
publié on va avoir ainsi à rêver des
mathématiciens et comme un des liens
legendre en 1752
joseph fourier aînés en 1768 siméon ii
ni poisson est né en 1780 jean-victor
poncelet en 1788 et augustin lui cauchy
en 1789 puis ça c'est aussi les
mathématiciens qui vont faire toute la
puissance de l'armée napoléonienne en
apportant leur expertise à tout
l'armement vise en éduquant aussi à
l'école polytechnique qui va être créée
à ce moment là toute une génération de
soldats et futurs commandants des armées
de napoléon
donc ça c'était pour les mathématiciens
mais au niveau des autres sciences aussi
d'avoir une explosion suite publication
de la traduction du printival
mathematica avec notamment charles de
coulomb qui en 1749 avait 13 ans antoine
lavoisier qui avait six en 1749 andré
marie ampère qui lui sera né en 1775 lui
il ya lui c'est qu'il n'est en 1778
augustin fresnel en 1788 et gustave
coriolis en 1795 et donc je suis sûr que
tous ces noms là vous les avez au moins
entendu à l'école voire avait une petite
fascination pour leurs travaux notamment
des loisirs qui le perdent et de chimie
avec absolument ce cas scientifiquement
fabuleux alors on peut se demander si
l'explosion des sciences et des
mathématiques dans une partie du xviiie
siècle en france est vraiment dû à
emilie du châtelet où est-ce qu'elle ne
serait pas plutôt dû à la pensée des
philosophes des lumières qui date du
début du xviiie siècle notamment
je pense que les deux on veut leur rôle
mais ce que j'aimerais suggérer c'est
que peut-être que la philosophie des
lumières et peut-être conséquente de
personnes comme ai mis du châtelet qui
ont mises en avant nos seuls mandats
sciences et les mathématiques mais aussi
l'appréciation des mathématiques et des
sciences
notamment il faut savoir qu'il du
châtelet à une
relation amoureuse très longue avec
voltaire notamment et que l' influence
de voltaire sur me du châtelet n'est
peut-être pas plus faible que l'
influence des mets du châtelet sur
voltaire et sas a sans doute contribué à
donner envie de la voltaire du cas de
promouvoir les sciences et les
mathématiques
en général on peut se demander si
finalement émis du châtelet n'est pas
l'une des personnes qui auront le plus
contribué au développement des idées qui
ont conduit in fine et à la révolution
de 1789 c'est peut-être aller un peu
vite en besogne que tu affirmer ceci
mais je pense que ça sera tout aussi
vite en besogne et de réfuter l'idée
selon laquelle elle n'a pas eu un rôle
où un poids significatif subtil mais
significatif sur l'évolution de la
pensée en france j'aimerais vraiment
insister sur ce point parce que c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle
j'admire le plus family du châtelet
s'agit d' une communicatrice au final
des sciences et des mathématiques et n'a
pas forcément découvert bref et quelques
dépliants mathématiques mais là bas fait
forcément une très très grandes
découvertes mathématiques à la hauteur
de celle de newton mais elle a promulgué
sans doute simplifiée sans doute
éclairer la pensée du tome yen ce qui a
permis de mieux la faire connaître
en tout cas en france et c'est au moment
où cette théorie on était mieux
expliquer mieux répandue qu'elle aura eu
tout l'impact qu'elles pouvaient avoir
il me semble que souvent on raconte
l'histoire des sciences des idées on se
concentre énormément sur quelques
penseurs qui sont à l'origine des idées
mais on oublie les personnes qui
diffusent simplifie
ray exprime popularise toutes ces idées
or ces personnes là où finalement un
rôle peut-être au moins aussi important
sur le développement des îles et et des
sciences à travers l'histoire donc
l'autre exemple qui vient à l'esprit
c'est celui de gallois gallois il est
mort très jeune et personne ne l'avait
compte mais ils avaient ensuite des gens
comme lui ville ou au jardin qui ont
créé expliqué les idées de diallo et ce
n'est qu'une fois que ces gens là ont su
bien expliquer bien communiquer les
idées de gameblog gallois avait très
maladroitement expliquer un peu comme ça
en automne très maladroite on expliquer
certaines idées sont print mathématiques
à ce n'est qu'après cette popularisation
et clarification de ses idées que ces
théories là ont eu vraiment des impacts
énormes et notamment sa la fin vraiment
du xviiie siècle que toute la théorie de
newton va être bien comprises bien mieux
étudiés par les la place et la grange ce
qui va mettre un peu aussi est ce que je
fais moi la raison pour laquelle on
pense que ce que je fais est ultra
important c'est grâce à des gens comme
emilie du châtelet qui montrait que ce
que je faisais avec peut-être une
importance insoupçonnée bien plus grande
que ce qu'on pourrait croire que si on
essaie de suivre un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé dans l'histoire et les
bornes d'histoire des idées de termes on
se rend compte que ces gens là qui sont
des intermédiaires entre les chercheurs
les découvreurs et les futur découvreur
où le grand public une puissante que ces
gens là où un rôle ultra important et
c'est pour ça que je fais tout ce que je
peux pour faire poursuivre les pas de
ses ventes et géant là et fait faire à
mon échelle ce que les milliers du
châtelet entre autres a su faire une des
chaînes tout info crânienne mais bien
sûr pour finir cet épisode il me faut
aussi insister sur le fait que du chat
elle était une femme est une femme en
plus au xviiie siècle une époque où il
devait être encore plus difficile
qu'aujourd'hui pour une femme de percer
en sciences même si c'est encore
difficile aujourd'hui malheureusement et
je pense que la raison pour laquelle
c'est si difficile c'est parce qu'on ne
les y encourage pas du tout voire d'une
manière parfois subtiles parfois sans
faire exprès parfois n'ont voulu on
dénigre voir réfute certaine supériorité
de la femme du sursaut ou plutôt une
certaine supériorité de certaines femmes
au niveau de l'intelligence et les
capacités mathématiques et ça on le voit
très bien à travers des citations donc
non sur la page wikipedia de français de
paix mis du châtelet on peut lire des
citations qui sont assez c3 c'est des
boutons pour l'irak
notamment il ya une citation de la
marquise du des fonds qui dit que
quelques célèbres que soit madame du
châtelet
elles ne seraient pas satisfaites si
elle n'était pas célébrer c'est encore à
quoi elle est parvenue en devenant l'ami
déclaré de monsieur de voltaire c'est
lui qui donne de l'éclat à sa vie et
c'est à lui qu'elle devra l'immortalité
en gros la marquise du défaut est juste
en train de la de dépeindre une image de
duchâtelet qui est assez horrible qui
est genre quand il cherche à sceller
goûter qui n'a rien dans le fond quoi
qui tous dans la forme
alors que c'est pas du tout vrai on a
par exemple citation de voltaire qui dit
bon c'est sûr que c'est un peu bizarre
puisque voltaire était l'amant de
duchenne lève mais il dit jamais une
femme ne fut si savantes qu'elles en
parlent mais sur des milles du châtelet
jamais personne mérite à moins qu'on dit
d'elle
c'est une femme savante elle ne parlait
jamais de sciences qu'à ceux avec qui
elle croyait pouvoir s'instruire et
jamais dans par là pour se faire
remarquer donc bien sûr ce que dit
voltaire est biaisé mais si on lit entre
les lignes c'est le ce que dit la
marquise dufour a l'air clairement
biaisé aussi on sent énormément de
jalousie chez la marquise du défend de
toute l'attention qui donnait à madame
du châtelet et je n'ai pas eu tous les
to l'extrait de la marquise du deffand
bongo comme d'une certaine manière elle
ne peut pas être en compétition avec
emilie du châtelet au niveau
intellectuel va s'attaquer à vail à
cette supposée soif de gloire des mines
du chapelet et puis dans la partie que
je n'ai pas cité elle va s'attaquer
aussi au physique de 2000 du châtelet
bref ça c'est des coups bas coûts mais
la marquise du deffand n'est clairement
pas la seule à voir de tels sentiments
négatifs envers émis du châtelet
on a aussi madame de créquy qui dit je
comprends bien que monsieur de voltaire
et où la fantaisie de la faire passer
pour une savante mais je n'ai jamais pu
m'expliquer comment monsieur claireaux
maintien dont j'ai déjà parlé un peu
plus tôt qui a été rude et sévère avait
eu cette compétence là nous disions
toujours qu'elle avait dû lui donner de
l'argent et nous n'avons jamais oui
parler du génie sublime et du profond
savoir de madame du châtelet sans
éclater de rire c'est assez horrible
c'est dégoûtant comme comme cisco
visitation ça montre pire que la
jalousie
ça montre que c'est donc fort dix new je
sais pas exactement de qui madame de
cris qui part mais j'imagine que c'est
tout un groupe d'aristocrates de noble
de l'époque et qui du coup se moquer des
milliers du châtelet pour parce qu elle
parce que 1000 du châtelet cherchait à
travailler son intellect en savoir plus
et à comprendre le monde autour d'elle
et malgré les avis des experts qui
touchera embrasse le génie 2000 du
châtelet tous ces nobles la madame de
créquy madame la marquise du deffand et
j'imagine pas mal de meubles femmes
notamment comme cela se moquer laquelle
la phrase éclaté de rire donc c'est
vraiment c'est violent fois c'est d'une
violence inouïe il se moquait des
congrès complètement madame du châtelet
parce que à la bouche at elle cherché à
comprendre le passé ça ça m'a l'air
juste horrible et dans un environnement
comme ça donc c'est vous dire c'est un
prof qui m'a marqué du châtelet et plus
s'intéresser aux sciences tout court
donc s'ils avaient pu s'intéresser aussi
on sait grâce d'une partie à son père
qui la poussaient mais aussi à voltaire
qui était très admiratif en de de
l'intellect de dhimmi du châtelet qu'il
considérait être supérieure à la sienne
mais surtout on voit clairement pourquoi
les femmes de l'époque ne s'intéressait
pas aux sciences vient si si elle se
moquer des gens qui s'y intéresser
forcément ça donnait envie à aucune
d'entre elles de s'y intéresser les
blagues même quoi c'est horrible et moi
je crains énormément que dans notre
société d'aujourd'hui
ce soit encore le cas malheureusement
qu'on ait tendance à dénigrer ou en tout
cas ne pas apprécier les compétences et
les facultés mathématiques de qui que ce
soit mais des femmes bien sûr en
particulier
ce n'est pas qu'une histoire d'hommes
qui font ça je pense que c'est aussi une
histoire beaucoup de femmes qui qui qui
qui s'auto danny groulx qui dénigrent
d'autres femmes niveau intellectuel
c'est juste affreux c'est juste la fois
pardon si je regarde les statistiques de
seine ce forum déjà la première chose à
remarquer c'est qu'il ya 89 % d'hommes
versus conçu pour cent de femmes ce qui
est un ratio assez horrible c'est assez
horrible et par avance à peu préparée
chez tous les youtube heures
scientifiques y compris en biologie et y
compris lorsqu'ils sont gérées par des
femmes
ils se regardent encore un peu plus dans
le détail on voit que dans la tranche
d'âge des 18 24 ans dans cette tranche
là c'est à peu près ainsi un quart des
abonnés qui ont entre 18 et 24 ans qui
sont des femmes
par contre dès qu'on bouge à 25 34 ans
il n'y a plus personne qui est mais plus
de femmes quasiment le pourcentage
quasiment 100 % d'hommes et c'est encore
pire plus on monte dans les tranches
d'âge ce qui montre que les mères de
famille ne s'intéressent pas à ce forum
et je crains que cette façon plus
générale ne s'intéressent pas tout cas
pas autant que les pères de famille aux
maths et aux sciences et je crains
qu'une conséquence de ceci du manque
d'intérêt des mères de famille pour les
sciences et les mathématiques de soit
une cause de leurs peut-être leurs
difficultés d'apprécier les facultés
mathématiques et scientifiques de leur
fille et ceci est peut-être l'une des
causes des difficultés des femmes en
mathématiques et en sciences en général
alors je sais que j'extrapole beaucoup
mais j'ai quand même envie de dire que
si les mères de famille notamment
s'intéresser beaucoup plus aux sciences
et mathématiques qu'elles ne le font
aujourd'hui
non seulement le ratio hommes/femmes
pourra être beaucoup plus équilibré mais
aussi la science plus aux allemands et
les mathématiques se porterait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux parce qu'on aura
beaucoup plus d'esprits brillants et
notamment donc
ces femmes pour nous aider à mieux
réfléchir sur le monde et la physique et
les silences et les maths qui nous
entoure l'exemple des milles du châtelet
montre clairement que les femmes ne sont
pas pas moins de frais culte et
mathématiques que les hommes puisque ni
du châtelet était à son époque plus
intelligente que tous les français
homme ou femme plus généralement ce qui
semble vraiment très problématique à
l'époque mais peut-être encore
aujourd'hui c'est un espèce de
conformisme de volonté le conformisme
que révèle la citation de charles collet
sait pas trop qui sème soi est un noble
j'imagine qu'il disait juste après la
mort de madame du châtelet
il disait il faut espérer que c'est là
le dernier air que madame du châtelet
elle se donnera mourir en couches à son
âge c'est décidément prétendre ne rien
faire comme les autres
c'est scandaleux comme ça comme citation
c3 puis quelqu'un et puis comme ça le
mec est en train de souhaiter la mort de
madame du châtelet khl juste après sa
mort qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas dire et
alors mourir en couches à son âge en
effet madame du châtelet est morte en
1749 moment
d'accoucher elle avait à ce moment-là 42
ou 43 ans comme ça 3 alger tam ans à
l'époque et surtout il ya une espèce de
condescendance une espèce de l'espèce de
moqueries 2000 du châtelet et cette
moquerie visiblement cette citation elle
est due au fait qu'ils aient mis du
châtelet elle était pas comme les autres
et parce qu'elle faisait pas les choses
comme les autres notamment parce que
c'était une feuille s'intéresser aux
sciences
selon charles collet elle méritait le
mépris scandaleux que ces scandales ont
mis du châtelet sera refusée à
l'académie royale des sciences
ce qui est un créneau bizarre quand
restée la plus grande mathématisée ne
sont quand même pas
ceci dit les savants de son époque lui
reconnaissait largement non seulement
une curiosité une envie de comprendre le
monde mais aussi un génie de tout
premier rang
si le journal du savant écrivait quel
encouragement pour ceux qui cultivent
les sciences de voir une dame qui
pouvant plaire dans le monde à mieux
aimer s'instruire dans sa retraite qui
dans un âge où les plaisirs s'offrant
food préfère à leurs erreurs
malheureusement si douce la recherche de
la vérité toujours si pénible qui
allions enfin la force au grâce de
l'esprit et de la figure n'est point
d'arrêter parce que les sciences ont de
plus abstrait un très très bel hommage
et enfin je vais finir avec une citation
de voltaire de son amant de plus de
longue date
voltaire juste après la mort d'amy du
châtelet solitaire c'est aussi celui qui
s'est occupé de la publication de la
traduction du primaire mathématiques à
après la mort d'émile du châtelet tout
cas vraiment pour ça en tout cas
voltaire mai
vraiment beaucoup de respect et honneur
en publiant ce bouquin sans doute
changer la face de la france
voltaire écrivit un ami juste après la
mort de deux manades du châtel j'ai
perdu un ami de 25 années un grand homme
qui n'a voix de défauts que d'être une
femme et que ton paris regrette et au
nord